Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and since Sylvester
McCoy was just caught talking about a New
Master for Doctor Who Series 8, I thought
it was time to talk about or top 10 choices
for a new Master.
We need to think of people that would work
really well with this new more serious tone
Peter Capaldi is supposedly bringing to the
series.
Full disclosure, Sylvester McCoy said he knew
who the new Master was, during a recent convention
in Newcastle.
That means either he’s blowing steam or
there really is a brand new Master coming.
For the purposes of this video, let’s just
assume he was speaking truthfully.
And since this is a pretty big deal I’ll
try to get a follow up Q&A video out by next
Tuesday.
If you’re finding me for the first time,
be sure to subscribe to get it.
So first off we need to acknowledge the rumor
that Charles Dance who plays Tywin Lannister
on Game of Thrones has been offered the role.
Book readers will understand why that might
work out from a production scheduling standpoint
between Season 4 of Thrones and Series 8 of
Doctor Who.
Please don’t post spoilers in the comments
though.
But there are so many other similar actors
who have also been named as being in talks,
all of whom are every bit as scary as Tywin
Lannister.
So lets’ talk about our Top 10 Picks for
The Master including some of those rumored
people.
Number 10 - Billy Nighy.
Yes he did already appear in and episode as
another character, but The Master is meant
to be the antithesis of The Doctor.
And as we learned in the 50th Anniversary,
The Doctor is destined to become caretaker
of a museum.
So it would fit thematically that The Master
would also have the same type of job at some
point.
Nighy has played several grand villains in
I, Frankenstein, Pirates of The Caribbean
and the Underworld series.
It’s really his Davy Jones role that makes
me think he could pull off role though.
I always thought of The Master as a tragic
villain as depicted in The End of Time.
And that’s exactly what his Davy Jones character
was.
I’ll say that I have several vanity choices
and he’s definitely one of them.
Number 9 - Jason Isaacs.
One of a few Harry Potter actors on my list.
I really liked his Lucius Malfoy character
in the earlier films before Voldemort arrived
and cowed him into submission.
He has played more viscious characters, but
there’s something about the characters in
Harry Potter that gives them this old-timey
ness that I feel we’re going to see in Series
8.
Especially with that first episode back in
Victorian London.
I always felt like Doctor Who was kind of
a period story, so all the best actors on
the show were also good period actors.
Number 8 - Emma Thompson.
Harry Potter Actor number 2.
But only by coincidence.
Trelawny would be an awful Master.
Could you just imagine.
Thompson though is one of the great leading
ladies originating from the UK and she’s
at the right age to play against Capaldi’s
older Doctor.
She’s mostly known for playing non-threatening
characters and mostly her roles haven’t
let her be very evil in the grand sense.
But I would love to see her play someone analogous
to Voldemort.
I even picked he who must not be named as
one of my choices for a new Time Lord.
Doctor Who has a history of casting multiple
Harry Potter actors in the same episode.
Number 7 - Harry Lloyd.
Who better to play the Master in after a Dickensian
Series 8 opening than the real life great
great grandson of Charles Dickens.
Seriously, Harry Lloyd is related to Charles
Dickens.
He’s also had amazing roles in Devil’s
Whore and The Iron Lady as powerful characters
and he’s also one of two Game of Thrones
actors on the list.
Yes, he was Viserys Targaryen.
Crowned in molten gold.
Isn’t it a funny coincidence that he also
starred in The Hollow Crown.
The Master is really the creation of the Time
Lords, but he wants to be King of the Universe
just as badly as Viserys wanted the Iron Throne.
Number 6 - Chiwetel Ejiofor.
Mostly known for protagonists and now for
his work in 12 Years a Slave, Ejiofor previously
had an amazing run against The 9th Doctor
Christopher Eccleston in The Shadow Line.
So in a meta kind of way he’s had a practice
run.
Capaldi’s portrayal is going to be very
different than Eccleston’s so he’d have
to be a little more grand.
But he also played a very ambiguous if not
effective villain in Joss Whedon’s Serenity.
I don’t think that character would be passionate
enough to be The Master, but Ejiofor is just
so good I have no doubt he would be amazing.
Number 5 - Benedict Cumberbatch.
For fans of a certain age, or maybe everyone.
Cumberbatch is the most popular choice for
idosyncratic characters.
It’s like everyone has their list of favorite
actors and everywhere in the world he’s
somewhere in the top 5.
Which is why he’d probably never have the
time to do it.
But picture his version of The Master with
the wit and appearance of Sherlock and the
Voice of Smaug the Dragon.
The Master really is like the genetic blend
of those two characters.
Grand, evil, precise, calculating and terrifying.
Number 4 - Alan Rickman.
Dial it back from a dragon a little bit and
you have a much more practical villain, the
third Harry Potter actor on the list, Severus
Snape.
Arguably one of the best tragic villains or
tragic heroes in recent memory.
Depending on how you look at it.
The other evil role that really comes to mind
is his Hans Gruber from Die Hard.
He’s as admired for it as he is parodied.
Which I think is perfect for Doctor Who.
It’s a series that at both times is beloved
and just a little bit silly.
Usually the showrunner is mostly the one that
informs that second part.
The humor of Moffat’s run is slowly turning
into something else and if the rumors are
to be believed.
Coming to an end.
Number 3 - Gary Oldman.
Harry Potter Actor number 4 on the list, I
sense a trend.
One of the best character actors working right
now and willing to try just about anything.
He actually said that the main reason he took
the role of Sirius Black in Harry Potter was
because of his children.
Let’s hope that his children are also Doctor
Who fans.
Imagine a blend of his characters from Tinker,
Tailor, Soldier, Spy and Dracula.
Maybe even just Dracula.
What I’m saying is, I would love to see
Dracula be the new Master.
Didn’t Gordon Tipple’s Master look like
he could have been a vampire?
Number 2 - Malcolm Mcdowell.
One of the most iconic villain character actors
of the last 40 years.
I consider his Alex character from Clockwork
Orange to be a spiritual Father to Andrew
Scott’s Moriarty.
If Capaldi almost seems like he could be Matt
Smith’s father, then who better to play
the counterpart to John Simm than McDowell.
In fairness, he is the oldest person on this
list and seems more like a more sinister version
of Derek Jacobi’s Master.
And I really think they’ll go with someone
younger and a little more prominent in the
eyes of audiences right now.
Which leads me to my Number 1 pick - Tywin
Lannister.
I mean Charles Dance.
Due to the incredible popularity of Game of
Thrones it’s hard to think of him without
thinking of Tywin.
But outside of the rumors that he’s already
been cast, there are so many things that scream
“Yes” about this.
First, The pedigree of evil.
That actually sounds like a good title for
an episode.
He’s played several amazing villains and
is mostly known for playing distinguished
characters.
That is to say The Master will not appear
as a fool.
Then look at the perspective of the BBC.
They want the show to be as popular as possible.
The best way to do that is to find amazing
actors that are incredibly popular.
For more on this refer back to my Benedict
Cumberbatch choice.
Right now next to Walking Dead, Game of Thrones
is one of the most internationally popular
shows on television.
Meaning almost anyone who watches TV probably
knows and fears Charles Dance.
Imagine a more forthcoming version of Tywin
dressed in Victorian clothing.
Which opens a whole new topic of discussion
for a future video.
What should the new Master’s costume look
like?
And with that I’ll pass it to you guys,
let me know who you want to see as the new
Master and do you believe the rumors that
Charles Dance has already been picked.
Like I said I’ll try to get a Q&A video
up on Tuesday to follow up on this so subscribe
to get it if you’re new to my channel and
leave your questions.
Big stuff tonight too.
There’s a new Game of Thrones trailer that
I’ll be posting and new Walking Dead.
Right now click here to learn about the newest
actor they just cast for series 8 and click
here for my top 10 picks for new Time Lords.
Thanks for Watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!